david you've talked before about how the
modern republican party under trump is
basically just about owning the libs and
memes it's no longer about policy
does it matter if they keep on winning i
mean listen they didn't win
they lost in 2018 and they lost in 2020
so it's not clear that they're
continuing to win
but i think the the important question
is
when you have so many republicans who
don't really know anything about policy
um and you have so many republicans that
no matter what aren't voting for
democrats
policy really doesn't matter very much
when you put out policy and then you
fail
and then your constituents don't hold
you accountable anyway
why bother putting out policy at all and
there are some republicans who are
actually
taking this uh and running with it
madison cothorn this new trumpian
elected republican member of the house
of representatives
um one of his aides i think it was uh
someone in his circle said
we're not running a policy office we're
running a communications office which is
social media and interviews and
confrontations that that are visually
compelling and this type of thing
these are their voters right and if they
don't need to put out policy and risk
failing to achieve it
and the voters are more interested in
ways to own the libs and
memes and this type of thing then
they're going to be that's what they're
going to get and in fact
it's happening republican voters have
been fed a constant stream of propaganda
for about six years now right it's 2021
you go back to 2015 when trump started
uh running and they've rewarded this
behavior the guy who said without any
details
i'm gonna get rid of obamacare and do
something beautiful
i'm to build a wall across the entire
border i'm going to fix trade
except he ended up you know replacing uh
nafta with the i don't even remember
what it's called now but it was
more or less the exact same thing
they're fed the propaganda and they
reward the candidates that feed it to
them they're represented by the
political equivalent of internet trolls
and they love it and when your priority
is messing with the other side
making liberals feel bad or look bad or
whatever it becomes a feedback loop
the propaganda of fox news and of
republicans
gives an alternate reality to the
republican voter
so that the republican voter no longer
cares about policy and they use the
propaganda to say well i can't vote for
biden because he's a communist
socialist i can't vote for hillary
because she has parkinson's or whatever
the case may be
and then they don't and then it makes it
so republicans continue to say why run
on policy i'll run on memes
and this goes for elected officials this
goes for fox news newsmax oan
that's how they they push this stuff and
generally speaking
it works now you can make the case well
does it work they lost the house in 2018
they lost the senate in 2020 they lost
the white house in 2020.
i just have a hard time believing that
policy would have done better for them
because their voters have been so
propagandized too and that's the
question i'll leave to you
is there an advantage i know that some
of the
traditional republicans you get back
with a focus on policy
assuming it's the right policy but do
they lose
all of these trumpies who never paid
attention to politics to begin with
and just showed up for the mexican
rapists type comments
is it really a net benefit to go back to
policy for the republican party
let me know what you think bonus show
today
this is the last show and bonus show
before our break we are off next week
the show's not canceled everything's
fine we're just taking a week off to
regenerate some energy
and then we'll be back the week after
one of our sponsors purevpn
is giving you 47 off a one-year plan
which comes out to less than
six bucks a month purevpn makes you
anonymous online
and you can trust them they're the only
vpn with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week
for just 99 cents and you'll get 47
percent off
a one-year plan which is less than six
bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman